guys who doesn't love a good underdog
story David against Goliath Rocky Balboa
vs. Apollo Creed Captain America against
Thanos but what makes underdog stories
so special is that they rarely happen
usually David just gets the [ __ ] kicked
out of them don't believe me well here
are the top 10 stomps in eSports
starting us off we have a stomp that was
completely well expected coming into the
2016 na LCS spring split immortals or a
team comprised of superstar players and
a favorite to win the entire thing the
star-studded team faced off against a
rather unforgettable team impulse during
the opening week of the split we've got
to keep a formal former champions in
immortals on one side is a squad trying
to honestly find their groove with two
substitutes and a guy playing out of
positions so honestly if you like team
impulse needs maybe a minor miracle to
win this matchup and the result was a
completely unforgettable stomp in record
time basically one shots baby 18 minutes
I'm towards the nexus impulse could have
surrender if they wanted to and
immortals looking for blood looking for
the kill looking for absolute perfection
in this game both Nexus turrets down 8
minutes and 10 seconds rate over trying
to stay alive the Nexus is low can they
do it a perfect game at 18 fastest game
at na LCS history these guys you had
better believe the high club
at number 9 we have g2 esports dominant
victory over evil geniuses at the 2018
six major Paris now as Penta sports the
g2 roster defeated EG at the 2018 six
invitational which some consider by the
way the greatest r6 series of all time
and at paris EG were out for revenge but
we all know that sequels rarely are
better than the original shot in the
back again the second kill one more up
top and this series would be no
exception
not only the g2 3 oh the Evil Geniuses
squad they crushed them only dropping
two rounds in each of their three map
victories ouch
[Applause]
a 3-0 absolute destruction EG failed to
find the opener not a single map I hate
you were unstoppable with g2 are
unstoppable for number eight we phase up
with phase claims tournament run at ESL
one New York 2017 with a fresh new
roster faze clan put on one of the most
dominant tournament performances in csgo
history
[Music]
[Music]
not only did they annihilate their
opposition they did it without ever
dropping a single map which means this
tournament run can only be described in
one word stomp that is ridiculous
oh geez run at ti9 takes the number
seven spot on our list
they showed not only can you be dominant
on route to a little championship but
you can do it in style and those
engagements see Z&C trying to bring down
step it won't be enough these guys were
beating their opponents so bad they just
started feeding them whether it be
dropping flags
through divers welcome flight he can get
one punch in the hangar one punch man he
very clearly dropping sprays or Pharma G
made sure to stomp and style as they
secured the aegis of champions
from a championship run to a
regular-season stomp at the San
Francisco shocks performance during
stage two of the overwatch leagues 2019
season takes the number six for San
Francisco to beat you they want to
demoralize you not be long in the same
game with San Francisco they want you to
believe and this one is about as
demoralizing as it gets
now while there have been perfect stages
in overwatch League before the shock did
it without dropping a single map Cisco
shook completes the golden stage
they do not drop they do not drop a
series and I have to say we may never
see this benefitting from incredible
team chemistry a great coaching staff
and being completely flexible in any
meta the shock of the 2018 season
they're an 18-5 team but I you know I
don't know anyone could disrespect them
this much at the number five spot we
have what may finally settle the EU
versus n a debate with g2 taking on Team
Liquid in the 2019 MSI finals with both
teams coming off impressive upset wins
against two tournament favorites fans of
the West were finally rewarded with a
long-awaited
na versus EU final but rewarded might
not be the term na fans would use to
describe this serious
explodes it for one almost knocks to the
smithy no deaths just yet if I could run
away slowed down now by cats I'm gonna
come in sharpen quite a bit of damage
- for Gigi - not only three OTL they did
it in a humiliating fashion in a 70
minute and 43 seconds series
it is the fastest international bo5 in
competitive league of legends history
will surely fall and G to rip through
the hearts of Team Liquid a North
American fast as they secure themselves
in the top of the world there is no
chance TL comes back from this there are
already our Nexus turrets this is what
peak League of Legends looks like it
comes from Europe a world record g2
eSports 3
coming in at number four is the 2019
starladder berlin major grand final
between Astralis and a vanguard with two
impressive victories over vitality and
renegades of the hunka found themselves
playing the role of underdogs
David's two astrologers Goliath
unfortunately the Cinderella story does
not have a happy ending straws decided
that Jamie time was over and proceeded
to decimate a von gar in both Maps
beating them 66 and 65 and a two Mac
Grand Final that defines the word stomp
at least when it comes to see us go look
that's a nice little take on it but when
you're getting blown out of the water
this badly in the first map of the
series which we even on the desk and I
saw Twitter analysts as well saying the
same thing are the map fools not bad for
ever and go this is what we're talking
about this is why this is the biggest
mismatch this is why you should probably
leave now to beat the traffic cuz the
next map is gonna be exactly the same
way now at number three is Alliance
taking on nagging white shield during
the group stage of season 4 League of
Legends World Championship during the
early years of League the Koreans were
unstoppable and the only team capable of
beating a Korean team was though another
Korean team heading into the match he
already 4o najin team was heavily
favored to secure the W not NY shield
is going to win this game they are 4-0
I don't always predict League games but
when I do I prefer Koreans stay salting
friends but Alliance shattered and white
shield along with them
say it louder I heard you alliance I'm
gonna put y'all through can this media
members down executing a perfect game
that included 14 kills 10 towers and is
almost 24k gold lead this was an
unexpected win that nobody saw coming
well nobody except for maybe double ones
actually think this is gonna win for the
reason that I've just really not been
convinced by shield coming in at the
second spot on our list is one of the
most significant beat downs in StarCraft
brood war history the 3 oh sweet bees
who delivered against savior in the gone
TV msl season 1 finals way back in 2006
beasts who came into the final as a
fairly unknown up-and-comer against the
then reigning bonds [ __ ] there he
unleashed a strategy the world had never
seen before
he broke the meta that had remained
unchanged for years and turned the
tables on the standard Protoss vs. Zerg
matchup the SU rather than really trying
to stay too defensive stayed fairly low
on canons in the early game and just set
himself up to be absolutely non-stop
aggressive the pressure heavy in the mid
game which really threw Savior off in
the games with appearances
dubbed the be soo build it allowed a
Protoss to harass deserved through dark
templar and corsair units while
maintaining control over the map and if
you never play brood war perform suffice
to say it was a beat-down savior simply
had no answer and got swept as a result
[Music]
[Applause]
at the top of our list we have the
biggest stomp in fgc history sonic Fox's
30 no against perfect legend during an
exhibition money match at summer jam 9
in mortal kombat x after a
confrontational exchange on twitter
perfect legend eventually challenged
sonic fox to a first to 10 match at
summer jam 9 by the second match it was
completely evident that perfect legend
had no answer for sonic fox's play and
proceeds to get humiliated in every
possible way
[Applause]
while most people would just cut their
losses and move on
perfect legend and other ideas please
you're making philadelphia laugh all
around me philadelphia sighing oh please
please you should walk away now sir it's
our right foot way oh okay so before I
even like into a super long story when I
did say any words that you say he said
you have body me with buzzsaw
the results unfortunately stayed the
same
perfect legend getting 13 odd still to
this day remains the biggest stop
eSports as ever with all the meteor in
the world does not cancel command grab
this time this time he tries a job you
stop well guys if you made it this far
in the video you must really love our
content and if that is the case I got
good news for you our documentary series
story of is now in podcast form you can
download it on iTunes or wherever you
get your podcasts and there'll be a link
in the description below well guys
that's all she wrote for the top ten
stomps in all of eSports now if you are
still watching at this point do me a
favor stomp out the sub button and make
that like to dislike ratio a little more
one-sided and I will see you next time